o la equis su mujer observa lo que queda
del colegio donde varias generaciones se
han educado
en este salón hacíamos las reuniones de
antiguos alumnos ahora no hay nada que
vamos a hacer juntos tres misiles han
caído horas antes en este sector del sur
de la ciudad de mykolaiv que ha sido
golpeado permanentemente desde el
comienzo de la guerra decenas de
viviendas han quedado dañadas es el caso
de la casa de ludmila que en marzo ya
había volar por los aires el techo de la
cocina la onda expansiva de este nuevo
ataque ha roto las ventanas y ha dejado
las paredes agrietadas
no sabemos qué quieren de nosotros todos
los días nos atacan no pasa día ni noche
sin que lo hagan no sabemos cuál fue la
última noche que dormimos bien
su marido tiene cáncer y viven con una
pensión que apenas les alcanza en este
sótano han pasado la mayor parte de los
últimos cinco meses
dónde vamos y qué hacemos no sabemos
nada de
la resistencia a los ucranianos también
se ve reflejada en la rapidez con la que
arreglan los daños pero algunas veces
los hombres no dan abasto
muchas veces un solo ataque afecta hasta
30 casas cada vez hay más destrucción
desde la mañana esta es la quinta casa
que reparo
los ataques contra mykolaiv se han
intensificado desde que comenzó la
contraofensiva a las fuerzas ucranianas
para retomar la vecina ciudad de gerzón
a 45 kilómetros al sur este colegio
también fue atacado días antes cuando
uno les cuenta a los amigos y familiares
que están en rusia lo que está pasando
dicen que no es verdad como que no es
verdad miralo
andrei es uno de los profesores quiere
ser testigo lo que ha sucedido
no puedo entender como las escuelas
pueden molestar a la gente los
habitantes de mi cola ya están pagando
un alto precio en esta guerra muchas
personas mueren cuando salen a la calle
aún así la vida en la ciudad es más
activa que meses atrás